- [Instructor] We're
told a powerful magnet
is attracting a metal
ball on a flat surface.
The magnet is pulling the ball
at a force of 15 Newtons,
and the magnet is 20 degrees to the south
from the eastward direction
relative to the ball.
Here are a few vectors where
the magnitude of vector A
is equal to the magnitude of vector C
is equal to 15 Newtons,
and the magnitude of vector B is equal to
the magnitude of vector D
which is equal to 20 Newtons.
Which vectors can represent
the force of the team's pull?
All right, pause this video and see
if you can think about that on your own
before we do it together.
All right, now let's do it together.
So before I even look at this,
I'm just gonna look at the description.
It has a magnitude of 15 Newtons.
If we're talking about a force,
you can view it as a
strength of 15 Newtons,
and the magnet which
is pulling on the ball
is 20 degrees to the south
from the eastward direction
relative to the ball.
So if this is the ball right over here,
and if this is the eastward direction,
it says that the magnet
is 20 degrees to the south
from the eastward direction
relative to the ball.
So the magnet would be in this direction,
and this angle right
over here is 20 degrees,
and the magnet is pulling on the ball,
so the vector would go in that
direction towards the magnet,
and we know it has a force of 15 Newtons,
that's the magnitude.
So it has to be a 15 Newton
magnitude right over here.
So when we look at the choices,
choice A is interesting,
at least the direction looks right.
It looks like it's 20
degrees south of due east,
and they also tell us that the
magnitude of A is 15 Newtons.
So I am liking A, now let's look at B.
Well B looks 15 degrees south of due east,
not 20 degrees south,
so I will rule that out.
And also B's magnitude is
wrong, it's 20 Newtons.
C, the magnitude is
right, it's 15 Newtons,
but the direction looks like
20 degrees north of due east.
So I'll rule that one out.
And last but not least, D,
the direction is clearly wrong,
it looks like 15 degrees
north of due east,
and its magnitude is 20
Newtons, not 15 Newtons,
so I'd rule that one out.
Now to be clear a vector is only defined
by its magnitude and its direction,
not by its starting point.
So if I had some other vector
that looked like this right over here,
that had the same magnitude and direction
if this was right over
here, a 20 degree angle
and it had a magnitude of 50 Newtons,
then I would have
selected this one as well.
You can shift a vector around like this
as long as it has the same magnitude
and it has the same direction,
it is an equivalent vector.